[موسيقى]
الشهر التاسع من شهور السنه الهجريه يسمى
بشهر رمضان ورمضان من الشهور العربيه
القديمه سمي بهذا نسبه الى رمز الارض اذا
اشتدت حرارتها فكان يقع في شده الحرب وقت
التسميه ويسمى بشهر الصوم وشهر الغفران
وربيع الفقراء كنايه عن كثره العطايا
للفقراء خلال هذا الشهر كعطايا الربيع لنا
بشتى انواع النباتات فهو شهر المحبه
والالفه وله سلوكيات اجتماعيه ونمط حياتي
مغايرا عن الشهور الثانيه الصوم ليث وانا
الذي اجزي به صدق الحديث وصح عنه تعالى
صوموا تصحوا قالها خير الورى وبذلك اوصى
صاحبه
والان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ورمضان لهذه السنه في اوله جراند ثالث
واللياهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون
جراند ثالث ربيعا ذلك وفي نهايته بدايه
الحرب الفعلي وفي منتصف هجره الطيور
عالميا شكوت الى سرب القطع اذ مررنا به
فقلت ومثلي بالبكاء جدير اسر بالقطع هل من
معير جناحه لعلي الى من قد هويت
اطير
[موسيقى]